hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to planet hoth okay I
kind of fixed my problem of which I was
the cause of stupidity caps locks is not
Pro Mode hi oh thank you oh you're still
alive not for young unless I miss which
is always possible thank you come again
all right moving forward I wonder if
there's water no doodoo all totally
boned bread okay I got it quickly um got
the ladder better remember there being
something here oh yeah you that wasn't
something nuts nothing needed unless oh
Jesus Christ
oh man hi Hey look I found another
scavenger BOTS girl HQ you sure to have
your ration card stamped after every
meal we don't want anyone going hungry
out there okie dokie
alrighty all right I don't know what's
going on this way I thought I was
supposed to go up the ladder but maybe
not oh hi bye bye
hello goodbye
goodbye I barely knew you before I
obliterated you there we go all right so
I'm getting pretty damn wait oh I hear
it where is it Ferraro on the other side
of this I gotta get my soup fixed up
what's the dealio here I'm in a warm
weather survival suits just my helmet is
ballsed up whatevs Brit I'm not supposed
to go this way so I don't even have an
objective so let's just wander out in
the wastes seems like a good idea when
you're trapped out alone in a frozen
planet that you've never been to before
just wander around a bit duh does it
cook don't listen to logic with a [ __ ]
at that what is that haha Jesus mother
of pearl oh thank you oh hi coming from
these things like to pop about us no oh
I need to reload for the first time in
ever hi JJ Christoph you a-holes calm it
down a bit
nope oh you got through stop Adam trying
to shotgun as hard as I can definitely
going to get lots of materials to build
stuff with you fuchsias but I need to
get to some heat like now yeah [ __ ]
calm the [ __ ] down I need to get some
heat like right meow right now I need
some e hey no hey oh hey I said what ah
job a bruh
what up [ __ ]
okay that was a giant pile of [ __ ]
I just like they mob me all of a sudden
like ha ha ha I didn't even have a
chance I'd like no chance and also I
think I ran out of shotgun AMRO but that
was my bad
all right let's try this guy no I'll
just play the scavenger BOTS which I
already dead
duh Isaac Clarke doesn't like to repeat
his actions it's a one shot kind of guy
huh all right and they're gonna start
popping up out of snow like right there
back the [ __ ] up you chill come on are
you not dead blow their legs off and be
done no I thought I saw something
Jesus these guys are gonna give me a
heart attack other robbers more MORE
ah check us hey Pavo before I can react
who else who else want some
I didn't even need to use that I need to
not be this way I need to get inside
that building which is surrounded by
those necro douches no I said you I see
no ass in here now where is I saw the
hi-yah guy are your stop
hey hold God's a Clark ain't fooling
around this time No
blew the leg right out from under you
yes Isaac Clark - professional badass
for the likes of you let's get into warm
warm me up bread we need to huddle
together to share body heat le great
Ellie's not here
I need her boobs I need her boobs right
now what duh hey Isaac what'd we get
where is everyone the hennifer research
facility of the ridge we found snow soos
but there weren't enough to go around so
I decided to stay behind but might be
more down in the basement why didn't you
go down in the basement bro how the
elevator shot yeah we heard something
scratching around down there so we
didn't we didn't check oh man these
a-holes all right I gotta get this guy a
suit like now cuz this is like the only
character of the new cast that I
actually I actually like can't I charge
that up from here how do I get over
there that's obviously a thingy that I
can get to and I'm freezing where do I
go
how come on you give me my optional
objective locate a suit kiosk has gotta
be one I know I'm looking for like a cog
or something I'll come on this man is
dying
ladis I am him here to save him he's
gonna die rue and I'm gonna die because
I'm about to oh no way my temperature
isn't dropping so he's got to be another
way into that somewhere around the back
end I'll swing around see if I can find
it hold on buddy buckle he's the only
guy I like so I do not want him to die
and that's why he's a cool dude staying
behind so everyone else can survive that
guy's cool bro must find Heat or else I
die where the balls is the entrance to
the other one where is it where del
Barrio bar is it come on come on it's
gotta be here
it's gotta be brah grab a tray aimin I
like to quote myself because obviously
I'm so awesome for something oh come on
there's no all you gotta be kidding me
he's gotta be Anaya don't got Tecton
Yeah right yeah I'm gonna I'm seriously
I'm gonna freeze to death out here
because I can't I'm a loon it's got to
be something here that I can use I mean
they wouldn't May it I mean it's gotta
be in here it's gotta be in here don't
die on me buddy
did you already die on me buddy he's
dead no oh okay it's go oh I probably
could have saved him
but I didn't I was right two seconds
from where I was supposed to go to heat
this place up yeah I could have done it
but I didn't that's poor guy toss that
in there oh that poor guy I was
literally like two steps from saving him
and I didn't okay I'm not that broken up
about it
yeah scavenger BOTS well ain't they
adorable okay let's see I knew
modifications I can pull got pretty good
ones no I can unlock those yes give me
another way to fire now two damaged
right if I'm no reload
oh I got no DubLi ones this is damage
rate of fire ones I guess it's a machine
gun show it wouldn't hurt why not Oh got
it nailed it all right I don't care
about that other gun I'm I stopped
caring about that other gun a long time
ago okay plenty of ammo lotsa I'm a holy
crap lots of med packs torque bars
daggit - just in case you never know you
do not know and I know now huh Paulie I
did save that guy man he died for
nothing he could have just walked over
here and saved himself oh ha idea oh
yeah you better run
don't you know who I am Isaac Clark
don't play no [ __ ]
I'm so sorry buck alike I really feel
bad but it kind of looked like you was
already way too far gone by the time I
got there I mean it's so sad the damn
other people for leaving them behind ah
man I'm really disappointed in the other
crews by the captain guy Michael don't
not to be infected then they started
changing
they keep sensitive to bright light just
shining my flashlight would send them
into a violent rage I disabled the
elevator to trap them down there god
rest her soul
Oh what about what can you do here what
okay what is this nothing no okay
haha what's what am i trapped down here
with hi like a skeleton I saw that on
the demo I think I think that was the
thing
uh-huh Oh oh man it's getting kinda
weird down here another compact standard
frame not that I need it okay I guess I
got to go through the body bag room oh
man I you know I actually don't know
what people had a problem with this
because that space 3 it's been
thoroughly creepy for me very certain
parts of it are just like like this
wonder just freaky I mean I think it has
a lot to do with the sound for me
because I love the sound of it alright
hey sound weird too
they're like ah ah Java me your [ __ ]
who you think you're messing with
No ah
star road stopped up heads out of you
the guy was trying to rip my head off so
those are things that ate infected flesh
that's a terrible idea on all accounts
who would do that good say look at a
Necromorph and go mmm I bet with some
barbecue sauce mmm
yeah I probably do that and it seems
like something I'd do Donna Lum is from
bottle gusano inaccurate hi Sam three
days I've been quiet mm-hmm I dated Arie
I stick to the radio call for help yeah
I think there may be a way around them
by throwing small objects I can I can I
can trick them into investigating the
noise okay for Sam remind me of that guy
from dead space one who was his name he
was another engineer good mom and very
tough they are definitely like the
little things from dead space to the
Horde of children basically what they
were they kind of make a similar noise
too and they're everywhere
I got a make sure to stop them before
the body is good
no son a better now shoot the shotgun
shotgun him hey I'm not gonna let you
that's my head get out my head I like
how the other ones just patiently
waiting there no dammit there's so many
of them all my AAMCO is gonna go i they
don't give me anything to throw it back
at him either at least the bodies are
sticking around that way I can loot them
all afterwards Jesus maybe I should have
stuck around and that was not good for
me what is that I want that I want that
let's drop one of these drop what was
that to dabble in one clip I could live
with that especially for the UM yeah big
one did the machine gun that were
actually the shotgun definitely cuz it
doesn't need that many bullets I don't
need 12 bullets in my shotgun 13
actually I don't need that many I reload
sooner than I'd ever need that okay I
have one scavenging
no go I please don't look look those
eggs are creepy as hell what is that
come on artifact you can't Kinesis
artifacts I haven't found any of those
what did I get
ah ba ba bla surviving's you sir we're
Arctic survival suit okay art whatever
okay I mean I know when it comes to
starvation versus you know eating
Necromorphs I think I'd pick starvation
okay there's something dozen all right
down into the pit we go okay all right
it's another one of these so I just got
to link them all so that the center
um but that unfortunately does not have
one of those so I get a link it up this
way like vouch one more there we go okay
and tada
what the hell is that demon machine
it's a trash compactor
with spikes why am i oh I see I get it I
get it I get it
thank you for the medkit I can't pick
that up but I can't trade off for a
smaller one I get what I'm supposed to
do watch and lay this passionate
pourquoi yeah I didn't even need this
stasis it's so badass for it well maybe
I'll need this stasis for my next
maneuver which I think is I have to get
it when it's all the way down hotcha
Botcha yeah like brows okay oh this
one's a bit more complicated try that
try no I need to do know that needs to
hook up down and lass no no no hang on
tag toe
nah bollocks that doesn't work either
yes missing just step one ah okay it's
gotta be near I wouldn't mark either ah
past
aha can't fool me too smart
be my big brain all right come on trash
compactor let me through Hey
Oh head shots kill him shad shots killer
badass
they move exactly like the little things
oh come on sweet sweet room see my
shotgun is amazingly ammo efficient
chick Chaka all right come on huh yeah
yeah fast ever greatest greatest in the
world like any of you had a doubt in my
incredible 'ti okay on our way to
victory more creepiness what is this
Spidey Bucky that's what I needed take
the security key and head to Depot 212
Franklin to the last week sure I do not
have to express the importance of the
supplies stored there I know what
happened to lovely and more importantly
okay so that's another optional mission
just for other stuff
what's your ma call it supplies they
said the word supplies and I couldn't
think of the words but okay Arctic
survival suit I don't need that but I
need to get into my witness suit which I
like better cuz it it shows off how
crazy Isaac Clark is ah I'm not crazy
everyone else is crazy I'm the only sane
one whoa look at this new suit man Oh
check out these digs oh god yeah and now
my helmet go good I guess you know in
terms of understanding the logic behind
you needing a specific suit for this
considering that your suit breaks aah no
no I was so close to tungsten off I
shouldn't have made that other torque
bar badge
what else can I upgrade all right
duration I guess really would like
another energy but that takes way too
much tungsten all right another donation
how about got Isis I haven't been using
that much my gun is Blake way too good
I'm not gonna waste tungsten on that my
guns way too good I don't even need it
please be tungsten what is it nothing
taste it back Thanks I know I can hold F
but I like mashing it
oh no if that's the same one it's dr.
Serrano you must make your way to
facility one do you hear me lives depend
on it
okay everyone just go then go now if he
if he could have gotten out I assumed he
would have done it a while ago
alrighty that guy's insane Oh Rama wait
a minute oh no way no no no no no no no
no no no no no no this is exactly where
I came in right I hope
I hope that guy's body up there is still
there and not turned into one
okay now I'm still sad because I really
wish he wouldn't have died I like that
guy
I'm not even gonna stomp his body and
you guys know how I don't trust dead
bodies
poor guy okay so I need to get to the
where over there look the weather
cleared up a bit and I'm oh man I feel
good I feel good man God feel good
whoa whoa whoa Tesla core hi that seems
important that they go I think I'll take
that I need to get in a guy got too much
crap where's this the bench
I need a bench those no benchmarking
that other building I need a bench I
need to put stuff into a safe God just
to pro got too many items don't need
nearly as many stasis packs Hanyu also I
just like the fact that I don't have any
money anymore I like being a super-rich
engineer I was nice and now I can't have
that anymore
yes bench thought so I was actually
gonna worry Hey hahaha
I was the little guy thank you scavenger
BOTS oh ah what happened ah my game is
crashing all right we're back
okay thankfully it did not go far from
my last play so I have already gone down
in the thing and I was I just met I do
all I had to do is walk right back to
the bench so all good here and now what
was I doing
I've totally forgot what I was doing oh
please tell me the safe that's it okay I
need to put something the safe and I
might as well upgrade my gun while I'm
at it get in there get in there get in
there and I'll keep all this glorious
ammo and let us change
I have tungsten now up unlocked I don't
need all those clip upgrades
I need dabbling and lots of it dabbe
boozing - clip dab leads blust clip made
a fire ah no more damage alright
whatever we're good and we're good okay
we're good let's get out of here let's
go we got to get through the security
checkpoint then get away from all these
diabolical demons haunting my dreams
yep still this way okay I was just
checking because I'll making sure that
the checkpoint system didn't put me
before safe and I needed to like do one
more step but I am good you know I don't
have a lot of faith in the whole
autosave system but this one was okay
okay
all right where we go why we don't up
here
what's with the Nets gaping rock slides
from happening
gotta find Ellie gotta find Ellie's
boobs I mean Ellie gotta find her
gigantic book ally gotta find Ellie huh
where am I going
can't hardly see
oh I remember now oh thank you
you guys are tougher to kill ain't you
this is part of the demo this is a
basically where the demo let in so this
is kind of bad no note there's a double
shot
gimme on something to throw yeah okay
nothing to throw it's okay I didn't need
anything to throw anyway ooh my other
scavenger BOTS is waiting at the bench
and I hear a scavenging spot I love this
cavern ik bot I can't believe I
neglected that at first I love the
little guy he's so cute
alright it was that a big med med kit I
think there was a big one
nope still medium I don't get the big
ones yet that's what she said haha
alright this is where shits about to go
down down hill
ah oh not downhill yet I thought that
was it oh this is it yeah no oh w naught
e mashing it looks like an e but
sideways
so badass god can't control how badass I
am God I'm so amazing
rickety piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah I dick
what a piece of [ __ ] yeah just for kicks
in shits and giggles I'm gonna use my
other gun just to see how crappy it is
compared to the good one oh yeah I
almost forgot about this view this was
like my favorite view in the entire game
when I was playing the demo because just
look at that hey let me get a scenic
view of Isaac like looking all badass in
pensively up at the sky door on Isaac
Clark reflecting on my own mortality
okay all right all done all done
reflecting dosn't Clark is immortal now
he's been changed by the marker but he's
not crazy
to ignore all the signs on his suit Oh
crappy gun crappy gun grab a hat
god join'd another good gun screw this
screw that noise no way am i dealing
with that okay now moving forward like
the bad as I am is a boss battle I smell
seems like it ah I wonder if there's a
friend out here I'm still alone
god I miss I'm not you
okay you could be a little bit better at
killing Necromorphs oh great how did you
make it the [ __ ] we thought you were
dead follow the trail of flares are you
guys alright
I saw Carver yeah yeah we're fine Cobb
is close we can hear him
look I said please hurry up and get here
we're in central come on I'll be there
as fast as I can
sounds like someone misses me
hahahahahahaha yeah score oh I'm gonna
get so late after I kill all these
Necromorphs oh yeah okay alright so
anyway as you all know there's a boss
battle waiting for me just outside are
you ready for the most epic awesome
amazing boss battle you've ever seen in
your gonna wait for it until the next
episode so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation wrong
videos that I've done and as always I'll
see you in the next video bye bye
warning this video contains scenes of
extreme violence which is awesome
hello everybody my name is markiplier
like brutal square with Jim Jim what the
hell is that dread Little Joe